[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney number one best-selling author
and host of the Dr John deloney show
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money open phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Merry Christmas America we're glad
you're with us Zach is with us in
Seattle to start off this hour hi Zach
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me uh you guys are
so my heroes and it's uh it's real cool
to be on the show
um I had a question for you guys so I
currently
um work at a tech company and I'm
looking to make a career change the
problem is
um I make really good money where I'm at
right now and what I'm wanting to go
into uh is a significant pay cut so I
make about 110 a thousand per year right
now uh with potential to move up I just
started the company so there's there's a
lot of growth there but I I'm not a fan
of what I do I took Ken Coleman's career
assessment gave me some great ideas and
what I'm wanting to go into is
firefighting which starting salary is
about 30 000 less a year
um and we're currently in baby step two
and we've got um with snowballing things
it'll probably take a year or less to
get everything paid off
um from kind of the snowball calculator
we did on your guys website so uh my
question is should I wait to do any sort
of career change until I've got baby
step two taken care of three to six
months in uh savings fund and then a
down payment for a house while I have
the higher paying career or do I take
the risk and go to a lower paying job
and kind of take longer to get you know
uh our finances all set up and a down
payment for a house because that's
ultimately where we'd like to go that
makes sense
so you want to abandon a perfectly safe
computer and run into burning houses
and I'm like I want to do something
that's meaningful to me and that sounds
a heck of a lot more meaningful have you
have you gone on a ride along yet or
have you do you have buddies here
firefighters
yeah so I got a buddy that's a
firefighter
um I've been doing a lot of research
into the career itself kind of what the
day-to-day looks like and all of it kind
of fires me up the people I've talked to
have loved it everyone that's kind of in
public service like an uncle that's a
copy like I wish I had been a
firefighter but a lot of positive things
about it from the kind of the research
I've been doing so far okay
all right yeah I would do the
ride-alongs too by the way but um yeah
um
what does the on-ramp look like how much
training how much down time
you you walk out of 110 and you walk
into 80. is that what we said are 70
what was it yeah you walk into uh they
have it all scaled out so it's 82. okay
so you're going to walk out of 110 walk
into 82 day one or after training or day
one for mine they're gonna pay you that
while they train you
yeah because you have to go to fire
school is that what they call it yeah
yeah so it's about 16 weeks it's from
what I believe it's 82 it might be a
little less than that but it's within
that ballpark regardless
um where it's about a 30 000 pay cut
yeah yeah and are you married
yeah married three kids
um all under the age of four what did
she make sure she'll die at home mom uh
she stay at home yeah she stay home
because the plan just keeps that way so
okay can you make your budget on that
uh yes it'll just take longer to do the
things we want
um well after 16 weeks uh you have what
firefighters call an extra job
because you generally work three on and
you build decks you're paying houses on
the other four
right most firefighters I know make as
much on their side gig as they do
fighting fires because they got this
wonderful schedule blocks set aside
yeah I know one guy made 100 Grand
building decks last year
and I had a buddy who was uh who got
certified while he was in fire academy
for I don't have me that shouldn't
that's cool welding or uh some kind of
engineer I don't know he got some kind
of incredible certifications where he's
making a jillion dollars on the side
yeah yeah sure you're not gonna work
three Beyond four all four you're gonna
work three and you're gonna work four
yeah yeah that's the plan that's that's
the other so your income's not going
down side Hustle
yeah it's true so you need to also
engineer your side Hustle
uh self-employed opportunity because you
can control the schedule and you can
work around and if you're going to paint
houses you just let them know I'm not
going to be there those three days
that's my fire gig and right you know
and
um you know again I think you'll find
around the firehouse that's a pretty
standard operation
so let me let me throw this at you
I always want folks who have multiple
kids like you do under the age of three
four or five
to Exhale for a minute
because everything in your life feels
chaotic you feel like you have no
purpose because you're funding the lives
of three kids who are too young to even
recognize you exist other than you make
them get in the bath and they don't want
to do that and change their underwear
semi-regularly and they don't want to do
that either and there's something about
you start searching for a place where
you can find meaning that's not at your
home
and so I Dave I I would I would tell you
if you were just my buddy and we're just
hanging out I would tell you get
yourself do a year Sprint and get out of
debt at least take that brick out of
your backpack at least take that
that
um that anxiety producing thing in your
life take it off the table and in the
meantime do some ride-alongs get to
um reading about firefighting is one
thing holding somebody in their front
yard while their house burns down or
pulling somebody out of a building and
trying to get them onto an EMS truck is
a totally different thing some people
are wired for that some people are not
and so you're in a unique position where
you could experience that and not have
to before you've you know completely
jumped off the dock
um but that'd be my recommendation to
you not a bad idea go serve man I love
that idea we need more firefighters and
police officers out there yeah thank you
for your willingness yeah I think the
um your side gig might be your
technology thing rather than building
decks or painting houses I might have
been wrong on that first wave it could
be incredible yeah because I mean
apparently you can work from home and
not work much see and get her like a job
doing that and stuff so um you know or
that some of the data says people are
working from home and they work they
won't stop yeah like 73 jobs exactly
well they have they I have four jobs
four full-time jobs working from home
see so by definition you aren't doing
any of them full-time but anyway okay by
definition so anyway but yeah that so
you could probably do a lot of I don't
know what you're doing if you're writing
code though I mean there's a lot of
freelance stuff you could do a lot of
contract stuff you could do and With
Honor with ethics and say I don't do it
except on these four days
um if you're doing the three on four off
gig or you could get into one of those
scams they call Consulting that would be
awesome
oh there we go
today Merry Christmas America this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Christmas America Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today Anthony's
with us in Panama City Florida hi
Anthony welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me on I'm grateful
to uh have the opportunity to talk to
you and John sure how can we help I got
a got a question just wanted to get some
opinion have some men speak some
knowledge into this uh my wife and I
want to own the campground someday um
we've come to this we call it a vocation
that we want to own one and we don't
know what that's going to look like as
far as something that we would fund
fully with cash to acquire a campground
like an RV Park Campground or a store if
you get a loan take on that to do so
so this is like a dream in the future
yes okay cool
how old are you guys
I'm sad I think about that for a second
I'm 30. no I was 28. okay cool when you
turn 30 you hear I mean start losing
your hearing Kevin I'm in your memory
right right away and your speech
patterns exactly um so why hey why
camping man what is it about camping
um well we both love it
um it's it's funny I'm like kind of a
jack of all trades master of none you
know I'd like to do everything and we've
been spending a lot of time at night you
know talking about what we want to do
with our future and we've settled on
this idea that yeah this is something
that could really get the gears turning
for us and keep us busy and we work
really well together and we'd like to to
do it together and we plan to like live
there too so like we see ourselves
living on this on the campground or at
least in close proximity absorbing and
you know taking on the lifestyle of
being Campground owners gotcha okay
well the first time you run a business
of any kind
uh you start finding out that you didn't
know what you didn't know
there's all these little surprises that
go
you know I had no idea and they're right
yep you had no idea that's why we got
you and uh you're gonna discover that
regardless of what kind of business you
own the first time you own a business uh
and run a business and it's more than
just keeping the toilets cleaned in this
case or the electrical hookups working
or whatever whatever jack of all trades
things you got all this other stuff
called accounting and marketing and
Collections and payment systems and a
website because that's how everyone does
everything now right oh maybe even an
app right and so yeah that's got a lot
that's a long way from uh running wiring
to the picnic shed okay and so you know
there's a lot of different skills you're
going to have to have running a business
that that you need to develop over time
and you don't want to discover those
with big hairy payments coming at your
face every month
I would rather you discover those more
gently than that so let's say that since
this is just a dream at this point let's
just adapt what some middle steps are
you're wanting to go from zero to a
hundred and one Leap and how can we do
this in the middle and I'll give you an
example I don't borrow money and I'm not
going to tell you to borrow money so
we're going to work our way through
there because I'm not that doesn't mean
I'm a dream killer either I want you to
live a dream but I don't want your dream
to be a nightmare
so I love in your case you love
campgrounds I love real estate
and um the a building that we moved into
a 55 000 square feet was a five million
dollar building and that was
um a uh 20 years ago I think something
like that uh let's just call it 20 years
ago and we didn't have five million
dollars but I really really wanted to
own this building kind of like you want
to own a campground you following me yes
okay so what did I do I leased it
with an option to purchase it for five
years I didn't have
a half a million dollars much less five
million dollars but I started collecting
all the Nickels out of the corner of the
couch for the next five years and barely
scraped together the money at the last
minute and exercise the option after
five years thank God I did because by
then the building was worth 13 million
and I bought it for five so what's known
as a freaking deal right and but I did
not borrow money and I was telling God
all along while I was looking for the
nickels in the corner of the couch if
you don't send the money I'm not buying
this because I'm not going to borrow
money period
and me and God had a lot of
conversations about that so I kind of
had to lay my guidelines out but during
that time I learned a lot about that
building we learned that the former
owner had not taken care of the roof and
the former owner had not taken care of
the heat and air and we learned that the
heat and air was from another century
and we had to go in and rework a bunch
of that and boiler you know baling wire
and duct tape uh how does this run
parallel to what you're saying maybe a
way to do something similar might be go
to work for Campground
be the general manager and maybe they
provide housing and you stay there and
you run the whole thing for an absentee
owner and that includes you doing the
repairs and you learning how to do the
accounting and you learning from the
owner how he did marketing for the past
20 years because he was doing this stuff
when you were knee-high to
nothing
and uh let's get in there and just get
it all over you a little bit and you
might discover you freaking hate it but
you might discover it's even better than
you thought and this is like awesome and
then you might be able to option it and
buy it from him with the profits
instead of with Dad
okay I'm making up a dream scenario but
I'd rather make up one of those and you
go get an SBA loan and call me up four
months later and go I'm broke oh by the
way covet hit and they don't allow
camping anymore
yeah because that never happens yes I
like the slower move into it like you
guys say when I watch solar you don't
want to jump or leap into it because
we're both gainfully employed now and
we're just thinking of the options how
do we keep it but I mean let's let's
just say what do you make a year
uh combined we're about ones no no what
do you make for taxes 82. okay well
let's say he paid you 60 to run the
campground you took a pay cut but you
got an option to buy the thing from him
anytime in the next seven years as a
part of operating it for him I'm
modeling after my little building deal
and you can make it up you can make up a
different narrative a different story
but the point is walk into it don't leap
into it and lay your structure out to do
that yeah I love I the word that keeps
coming to mind is let's practice before
we go to the major leagues let's
practice let's at least take some
batting practice before we realized it
before we decide that's what we're gonna
do forever I love that idea and even if
you can't get a job at a campground in
your local area get a job at um work in
the evening shift at a local hotel
hospitality industry because the
campground history it's off it's a lot
of people man it's a tough that's a
tough tough gig well and these are you
know if something's broken it's broken
like right then yeah and it doesn't
matter if it's 2 A.M that's right it's
broken if you live on so the reason they
let you live on site is because they're
going to come knock they want you to
come get it you are you are the
emergency toilet guy that's your job man
and I mean welcome to doing it that's
part of it's okay it's part of the gig
and there's nothing no downside of that
except that that's who it is good stuff
Caitlyn's with us Kalyn is in Atlanta hi
Caitlin welcome to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon how are you sir better
than I deserve Merry Christmas how can
we help
um so I am wondering I have about 17 000
saved up personally and
um I was wondering if I should a 9000 is
my uh three or my six month emergency
fund and I would like to buy a car
because I need something a little more
professional for my business and
um I was wondering how much of that
remaining uh would 8 000 I should use to
buy car or should I you know put off
buying that car and um start a Roth IRA
because I've been putting that off as
well
what's your income
um my income is 33 600. so what is your
profession that you need to look more
professional for
so I own a landscaping company and
um the truck that I've been driving that
looks professional
um will be going to my new crew and so I
need a vehicle while they're using that
truck to work to go run estimates and
errands and stuff like that
okay all right well
um I've had a professional landscaper
doing my office work and my lawn
personal lawn for uh 20 21 years I do
not know what he drives
okay nor do I care
okay all I really care about does a
dadgum lawnmower work
exactly
Caitlyn do you know what I drive
uh what do you drive it's an
embarrassment to me and my family it's
an embarrassment to all of us but you
don't know that's that's the point right
that's the point right you know you now
know it's an embarrassment but it's not
not great it's not great so no I I would
not look professional I would buy
something that's reliable and that gets
the job done that's what you always want
to do in business uh there's very few
things in business that you buy to
impress people that work
most of the things that you buy in
business should just give you a return
on investment meaning they should get
the job done for the cheapest possible
dollar so get you a nice little truck
that's dependable that'll do the
estimates and that's all you need and if
you ever lose a customer due to the
truck you drive you call me and I will
pay what he would have paid you to cut
the grass it will never happen man this
is the Ramsey Show
oh
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today uh with Christmas only a
couple days away we're fully in the
season of giving and that means we've
got a way we can give that you can give
like no one else you can give high
school students across the country the
gift of hope that same hope you found
maybe when you went through Financial
Peace University or you found listening
to this show our foundations in personal
finance High School curriculum teaches
students the same life-changing
principles you learn so when they get
out of high school they got common sense
they can avoid debt they avoid worry
avoid the stress here's the problem a
lot of schools don't have the funding
for these critical resources and that's
where you can help some of you are
sitting there where you're able to give
and through our curriculum sponsorship
program you can team up with us to get
this curriculum in the hands of teachers
and ultimately change students lives uh
you found freedom because you chose to
take the principles we teach
and apply them in your life now you can
help students to do the same thing
freedom foundations
foundations and personal finance for
high school if you want to help us go to
ramseysolutions.com sponsor
ramseysolutions.com
sponsor Ethan is with us in Traverse
City Michigan hi Ethan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave John it's uh good to be able to
talk to you guys you too yeah so you're
in the same town with our friend Meg
Meeker good good to have you Merry
Christmas how can we help
thank you Merry Christmas to you guys
um so my uh wife and I were just
recently married uh five months ago
congratulations
um thank you I appreciate it
um so since getting married I uh adopted
um
uh a bit of debt uh which is something
that I'm not too familiar with you
adopted it
well
um most of it was is not mine came with
a package oh okay okay okay man I was
slow on the uptick on that one dude my
bad sorry so she had a bunch of debt
that's now y'all's debt yes exactly Hey
listen on behalf of wives everywhere
thank you for your gentle language that
you adopted it as though it was like a
sweet puppy yeah it was her cat that was
very loving of you man her ugly cat good
for you two hours so how much debt did
you adopt
so
um a little a little under
um 100 000.
um so you adopted like a hippopotamus
not a puppy this is not a puppy Okay
Okay a large a large puppy yeah all
right 100 Grand and what's your
household income
yeah the householding income is uh it's
about uh 58
okay and you two are on the same page
about attacking all of this I assume
uh yes here we are good how can we help
so um
I guess my question is um just uh
you know that is something that I'm not
too familiar with so uh yeah we got that
that's your nice way of saying stressing
your butt out I got you okay yeah
as promptly as possible while still
being able to uh enjoy
um being newly married and um kind of
establishing
um our house and our
um bringing in uh you know furnace
furnace uh Furniture into our apartment
and um also
um a dream of ours is to one day uh
start a business together so how did
this I guess navigate all that did you
want the truthful answer or do you want
the uh Pinterest answer
uh truth or answer I'm not huge on
Pinterest so I'm not interested I didn't
know Pinterest was lies but that's
pretty uh it's just butterflies it's
just pretty pictures is what I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah truthful answer please
I think my wife and I were married 10
years because of the whole I dug
when we both were participated but
mostly me
um
to the tune of six figures and a whole
bunch of degrees
before I finally was able to
buy a
uh headboard on Craigslist that I spray
painted in my backyard
here's what I'm telling you
long term in your marriage the smartest
thing to do right now is to pay your
debts off
borrow Furniture get crummy for get to
the next stage man but you have this
picture of what you thought your first
year marriage was going to be like and
you'll have six figures in debt and you
can have all the pretty Furniture in the
world and all the nice cars in the world
and all the new businesses and that debt
will bury your marriage and I know that
because I I've done it I lived it
and I kept punting it and moving it
around and trying to do this and putting
things off instead of just sucking it up
and getting that stupid stuff paid off
here here's what's weird
um when you guys
decide together
and you take her two hands and your two
hands you look into her eyes and you
decide to spend the next uh 24 months on
a garage sale couch that cost thirteen
dollars and is pinkish blue but we're
not sure what color really
when you decide to do that you're going
to laugh about those days later
and uh you're certainly going to be but
it's actually going to the weird thing
is it's actually going to increase the
quality of your relationship and your
marriage more than the new couch will
by a hundred miles because we're working
together for a common goal and we're
sacrificing together for a common goal
and when you guys do that when you pay a
price for something you both believe in
early in your marriage together it knits
you together more beautifully than
buying everything looking perfect than a
hundred thousand dollar wedding a two
hundred thousand dollar car and a three
hundred thousand dollar new business
um and you know so a crummy wedding day
when it rains and the mushroom caps
float and the little thing and because
you did it outside and you didn't think
it was going to rain and that knits you
together a you know it sounds weird like
I don't want to sign you up for
suffering but you've already adopted it
so there you go you signed you up for
something so let's get after it so
working extra jobs living on a budget
the both of you being in agreement not
you dragging her along because you have
anxiety about debt but her being in
agreement that hey this is a mess we're
both going to work on this we're both
gonna lock arms we're going to put equal
emotion National effort into it
and we're going to sacrifice to win for
a short period of time we're going to
live like no one else so that later we
can live and give like no one else
your business opening is going to be
down the line after you're out of debt
have an emergency fund saved and then
save up some money to start your
business right now you're just going to
work your butts off both of you and both
of you aren't working enough you got to
work more
here's another cool thing you'll buy a
different couch
in 30 months than you would right now
because you know how much a dollar is
worth and how much a thousand dollars is
worth and you're not going to buy a 5
000 couch yeah and so I start doing math
if I'm you okay thirty three thousand
dollars a year it means I'm out of debt
in three years fifty thousand dollars a
year means I'm out of debt in two years
and how am I gonna do that making 58 I
got to make more money I gotta have more
money coming in and I and I can't spend
money on anything because I don't have
any money we're not going out to eat
we're not going on vacation you're not
going to see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're freaking working there but
guess what you're the first Oh no you're
the second generation that thought you
had to eat out every night your first
year of marriage
every other generation the bride had the
pleasure of burning meals for a year
trying to figure it out
and then you can laugh about that too
and my wife is actually a good Southern
cook but she still screwed up a lot of
stuff the first year and you know how
much I screwed up none because I didn't
do nothing so there you go screwed that
up too so there you go but uh so I just
got the pleasure of her being mad when I
was making fun of her but anyway it's
all good so you know but no I mean this
is how life Works y'all it's okay it's
okay to for everything to not look like
uh Instagram because that's someone
else's highlight reel their kids still
pooped in the floor three minutes before
they did those little white suits and
put them all together
three minutes before
in the floor what are you thinking you
know they did I know those kids that
wear those white suits you know they did
that there's Cha-Cha everywhere in that
house everywhere
so yeah don't follow other people's
highlight reels sacrifice to win pay it
off now if you have a shared Vision very
detailed very laid out where both of you
are in agreement on it and then get your
butt in attack mode that'll be the best
thing ever happened to a young marriage
is to learn to accomplish goals together
through sacrifice through goal setting
through hard work you can do that you
can do anything my friend anything
nothing will stop you this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS America we're glad you're with us
this is the Ramsay show Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Dr John
deloney show is I said Dr John deloney's
show is what I said was but that's okay
it's still it's all it's all here it's
on person that's right all right let's
just move on Lee Leah is with us in New
York City hi Leah how are you Hi how are
you better than I deserve how can I help
well I'm calling because I have a debt
problem I have over 1 million in debt
that includes a home a college loan and
um credit card debt okay and how much is
your home how much is the debt on your
home
it's about
um
500
000. and what is the house worth
it's worth about a 700
000 now okay all right and so you have
five hundred thousand dollars in other
debt I'm guessing a larger portion of
that is student loans yes student loan
how much
um about three hundred thousand you have
200 000 in credit card debt
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I thought you
said you had a million you got 500 000
on the house 300 000 in student loans
that leaves 200 in credit card debt no
no actually it's maybe less than it's
about 30 in credit cards 30. yeah so 470
in student loans
I have about three three hundred
thousand so you don't have a million
dollars in debt no I don't I thought it
was him but maybe I just okay so 500 on
the mortgage 300 on the student loans
and 30 on the credit cards and that's
all your debt
well yeah that's about and they have a
PhD about that so what what is your what
is your you have another loan what's the
other loan it's a car loan how much do
you owe in your car it's about twenty
four thousand
okay and so are you a doctor or a lawyer
um neither I just work in in healthcare
300
000 to do what what's your degree in
um uh it's more like a like a a
management type degree like a
certificate that I just got her end up
getting a really good job
so what's your income
it's about 120 a year
are you married
I'm married but I'm mostly responsible
for my own bills not anymore what is his
income
I I don't know it's not a you know I
don't know
how long have you been married
about 12 years
okay
if you were going to guess does he make
60 or does he make 600.
I I'd say he's in the what was that
about
um he makes maybe about a hundred
thousand I would say okay I don't know
the exact amount okay
all right uh and I assume he's on the
mortgage as well right yeah yeah
that's important all right
but he won't he won't have a
conversation with you about money
no I I've read
your what reason does he tell you he
doesn't want to talk about money I
I don't know
hmm yeah you do yeah
what did he say
he just doesn't
he just smiles and says Nope and then he
says pass the nachos no yep we just no
it's very very rare that somebody has
that sort of disdain for the human being
they share a life with that doesn't also
come with other abuse or other sorts of
deception or Affairs or things like that
okay well you know what you're talking
about okay okay
are you safe now
yes
okay
okay I I don't know if that was she was
agreeing with her statement okay I'm so
lost right now um
all right
um
okay let me go back a second I'm gonna
I'm gonna pan back way back Leah uh how
long you guys how long you been
listening to this you said you've got
all our books and stuff what's that mean
yes I've been listening to you I say for
maybe two years now when I first heard
about you like right around covid so the
wonderful thing that we discovered
25 years ago or so
is that personal finance is more
personal than it is finance it's 80
Behavior it's 20 head knowledge
your math that you're describing to me
is very stressful for you
terrifying for you
um and it is the result of
um
the the series of decisions that you
brought into your life including this
dysfunctional marriage
um and so the math is not going to get
better until you get better
uh and so the the way out of this is uh
a different level of wholeness than I've
heard in this conversation I'm not
putting you down I'm not shaming you I'm
just saying that you and your husband
working together making two hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year living in
a house that you owe a half million
dollars on trying to pay off your debts
and uh having a wonderful flourishing
marriage where there's great
communication and shared goals and
shared dreams is the way the only way I
know how to teach you to get out of this
debt because this is so such a personal
situation and the more the more you have
to fight against
um
uh dysfunction
while you're trying to clean up this
mess the harder it's going to be is that
does that sound unloving when I say that
no no I've I've heard it before okay are
you are you
do you believe you've you've with
student loan with your car with the
other loan
that you are unable to leave
um
yes a little bit and the you know I'm
just um
I'm I know you're being very very
measured and careful in what you're
saying and I get that and I want to
honor that I also
um and I I'm you know you know because
student loans are in deferment I haven't
really you know touched that for a while
and
um
it's uh
yeah so 350 000 solves your problem
if you do that thirty five thousand
dollars it takes 10 years
if you do 70 000 a year it takes five
years
uh-huh and if you do it at a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year it's done
in two and a half years which is what
your combined finances would allow you
to do
if both of you had a shared goal and a
flourishing relationship or you by
yourself without this mortgage on your
back
um have to say I make 120 I've got to
cleaned up 330 how fast can I do that
um and it's not and by yourself I mean
that is like by yourself now you're not
with him anymore kind of by yourself
so I want good things for you we love
you we want you to win I want you 10
years from now you to have a good life
and
um it doesn't sound like much fun right
now from where I'm observing and so if
I'm you I'm going to start taking some
steps to force the fun to come
yeah and
I want to recognize it what I'm about to
say I'm is it it's a much different me
saying it on this side of the of the
railroad tracks versus the side that
you're on
but your safety
and your wholeness within a marriage and
your ability to communicate in your
ability to be able to
fully go to sleep in a home that you
feel safe in is
um
is not doesn't have a dollar amount on
it
and whether you need to call somebody
and let them know that you you need some
help or you need to reach out to an
organization in your community or reach
out to some friends or to family members
whatever that may be it sounds like you
are there
and again I want to honor the fact that
you want to go into too much detail and
you want to to
kind of let us know what's going on
without really letting us know what's
going on but it sounds like you are not
safe
and it sounds like you owe a lot of
money and if you were to leave today you
don't believe that you have enough money
to pay your bills
and I don't want that fear which is very
real to stop you from making a phone
call let somebody know that I'm not okay
because like Dave said I want in 10
years man I want to I want to meet you
in person I want you to be smiling from
ear to ear because you chose today is
the day that I'm worth more than that
that puts the shower of the Ramsay show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as dumb
Cassius king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Merry Christmas
America we're glad you're with us
Beverly Is With Us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Beverly welcome to the ram station hello
Dave how are you doing doctor how are
you doing we are better than we deserve
how can we help
I'm trying to get there too okay this is
my situation my husband he died in 2021
May 2021 okay of course we're not a will
I was not living but Pam we've been like
separated but not legally for about two
decades we have children and which are
grown of course
I'm trying to do this probate thing my
problem is that I I have to hire a
appropriate attorney because what he did
he did own a house okay it has it has a
tax value of like 170 which I think is
flying out because he didn't take care
of it and the problem I'm having with um
probate is because he didn't file um
taxes with me within the last um two
years one or two years
um I have proof um have difficulty
proving that we've never done a divorce
because in Philadelphia
the rules state that um okay
um that you have to do the taxes you
know if you um because they cannot tell
there's no divorce record do you
understand where I'm going with it they
can't prove that you were married at the
time
so I'm having to go to this um
yeah that sounds backwards
he lived in he lived in Philadelphia
and I live in Atlanta okay and uh you've
been separated for 10 years that's weird
well more than 10 more than 10 really
that's whacked okay so why do you think
you get the house because you basically
were divorced
well we're divorce of Legally uh I
understand but why do you even think you
get the house morally
You've Been Gone Girl
why not I mean what's along with that I
mean I wasn't asking about the law I was
asking about what's right you weren't
married for the last 10 years plus 20
years 20 years in a very real way I mean
technically you are because you guys are
weird but you said you said you've been
doing your taxes together up until two
years ago we have not been doing our
attacks together but I have been
receiving so we're both um veterans
right I'm a disabled veteran I have been
receiving
um veteran and Social Security pension
through him
and me because I served also but I
received you know through him
all these years until the day he died
yeah and I guess whatever widows uh
because you're still technically married
you get that and the Veterans
Administration probably isn't looking
into it but when you went to Probate
Court uh the people in Philadelphia went
uh you kind of like need to show us
you're not divorced and two years of tax
returns would do that uh obviously the
law in Pennsylvania is not that if
people don't file married filing jointly
for two whole years that they are
automatically divorced Under
Pennsylvania law that is not the case uh
so something else is going on here when
you went into probate I know like
somebody's fighting you like one of the
kids says you shouldn't get this house
no no the kids are you know backing me
up which I could do okay
um have one of the children go up there
but um we did take a trip up there but
this paperwork was wrong and I'm just
like tired of you know spending my money
supplying the house worth actually if
you were to put it on the market on a
real estate agent
[Music]
um that's another thing too the tax leg
in the house is 170 right but it's in
Porsche what is the code what would the
house sell for if you put it on with a
real estate agent
to run a real estate agent I might get
174 but you know the tax value of it
okay so if you could if you could sell
it for 170 because you're not moving to
Philadelphia that's what you're going to
do with it then uh what's it what's owed
against it
all of my life 17 000 in back taxes
that's all right I am paying yeah which
I am paying you know if you had a
payment he had no mortgage
no he had no mortgages now
okay what do you make
what I mean I make them through my VA
Social Security like 4 800 and how old
are you
oh I am 63. okay here's what I would do
I'm the same age as you okay I'm getting
ready to be I'm 62. if I woke up in your
shoes
um which I can't imagine but if I did
because I got to tell you if I left
Sharon for 20 years one of us would be
dead but yeah
anyway
but if I woke up
dude I would I would hire to get a 170
000 asset as the wife of a dead guy
um The Legal Wife of a dead guy no
divorce occurred and uh there's no one
arguing about this no one's anything we
just need to get the house deeded to you
so you can sell it you need a judge's
order from probate court to be able to
sell the house I would just hire a
probate attorney
that's what I did I I mentioned it and
they said you just can't do it and it's
impossible no he didn't say he didn't do
it I just want to make sure that I'm
doing this because I love the way you
know if somebody's doing something
stupidly I love the way you tell them
hey you're being a fool okay no you're
not you're not being a fool if you're
hired an attorney to work you through
this very complicated and uh unusual
situation
um you're not being a fool at all in
that regard no no and uh because you
need to get basically you need to get a
judge's order in Probate Court to be
able to give to the title company so
they can issue a title because the guy
that's on the title is not here to sign
it
and so the you know the you have a
ruling from the judge that in allows the
title company to write title insurance
and the judge is going to say oh okay
this lady's the they never they were
separated forever but they never got a
divorce and there's no Pennsylvania law
that makes you instantly divorced and so
we're going to issue a ruling that says
this house is to be sold and um
Miss Beverly from Atlanta can sign the
deed and you mentioned I heard you
mention that you had to protect your
children
um
if they give you grief over it you can
tell them no he he left or I left keep
us safe and we just never got around to
the divorce it does it you are going to
have to explain that at some point why
you didn't never file on it whether he
was she just mentioned that whether he
was abusive or he wasn't safe to be
around
um oh is that why she said she left oh
okay okay um said she had to protect her
children which I understand well that's
a different issue but I also understand
um the divorce process is messy if
somebody wants to drag it out I get all
that but 20 years is a long time a long
long time now closure closure's worth
your time and your money yes yeah yeah
painter get off the ladder yeah that's
that's the plan so yeah
um
[Music]
is that the guy on your Instagram I saw
you said what I'm worried about dealing
with my daughters dating and where I'm
hide the bodies and he went
on a second thought I'm not no not
worried about where he's gonna have the
bodies
[Music]
I literally have no idea what you're
talking about uh well it's just like
that's what would happen if I was gone
for 20 years and didn't get a divorce
this was the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America hey Ramsey fans we got something
new going on over here check out our new
Ramsay apparel oh my goodness it's
happened custom designed to remind you
why normal sucks and why you choose to
be weird so t-shirts hoodies all kinds
of fun stuff sweatshirts the whole thing
Cassius King better than I deserve live
like no one else you got one on I do I
look like a smoke show not even gonna
lie I look pretty good I can feel my own
body heat right now
I don't know I said that sorry
if I'm just real quiet what will happen
now the room just listen you get one of
these Ramsay sweatshirts I will lose
weight it's got Spanx built in
yeah I can't breathe I haven't taken a
full breath since I know why you looked
like I was trying to catch I'm just slow
okay yeah it's there John you're they
look great you're amazingly handsome
trusty Dusty Ramsay sweatshirt on thank
you for saying I was answering oh my
goodness go to ramseysolutions.com and
get free shipping on orders over forty
dollars because you're gonna win a lot
of these
ramseysolutions.com wow that just
happened all right Jason is with us
Jason is in Chicago hi Jason how are you
hi guys thanks for taking my call Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas to you what's
up
um I'm actually in the sticks uh about
90 miles from Chicago
um my wife and I uh just remarried we
were recently divorced and uh with 48
and 40 about 110 000
um income they remarried each other
no
I was previously divorced in oh okay you
you have remarried after the divorce I
got you okay you said my wife and I I
got confused okay sorry yeah
um yeah I have 30 000 in debt and we're
in uh baby step two
um we have 70 000 in the bank from the
the sale of my house and we're currently
renting and driving about 50 miles
opposite directions
um and we have an opportunity to buy a
piece of land
um that's kind of smack dab in the
middle sounds like you are I think
you're driving 50 miles each Direction
sorry I'm actually driving a hundred
miles right now we're looking for land
that's
um in the middle so that we can both
Drive about equal distances
um so this land this opportunity is is
about in the middle
um
So eventually each one of us would be
driving about 50 miles One Direction
um for our for our jobs what do you do
what do y'all do
well we're both we both didn't replace
an employment for for 20 and 25 years
um yeah but you started a whole new life
together so yeah that's important but I
also don't care what do y'all do
I'm a design engineer um she manages a
salon A Day Salon okay
I uh I read some research recently that
suggested that
some of the rise in mental health
challenges that are going on in the
country is continually increasing
commute stressors from distance and all
to say is that is a significant amount
of strain you're putting on your young
marriage but yes that's neither here nor
there that's not what you're calling I I
wouldn't do that if I were you is all
I'm saying just just friend a friend
and I get it I have I have looked for
jobs uh Out close to her area
um but I have three children
um All Above 16 and it is
important for me to be able to see them
and it because I'm going that direction
for my job it it also helps me to
maintain a relationship with them
they're not salons in that area that
your wife might consider taking over
yeah we're talking about that too um
uh without getting into too much detail
on her her um
she's well taken care of in the salon
that she's in okay here's the thing no I
would not buy the land
yeah if it were perfectly situated and
your situation was perfectly situation
situated which we've all agreed in the
last few minutes it's not
um even then I would not buy it okay
let's say you both live two miles from
it oh you both worked two miles from it
and the kids were three miles from it I
still would not buy it because you're in
debt I would have you to get out of debt
and build an emergency fund first
and um once you're 100 debt free in
other words I would write a check today
from the sale of your house and keep
renting and I'd be debt for you today
now then I'm going to start talking
about how we can build a quality life
together and spending an hour and a half
on the road every day oh that's morning
and evening I'm sorry three hours a day
on the road every day
um is not conducive to anything good
it's just not it's not a quality of life
and so I know where Road Rage comes from
it's when I'm in traffic more than 15
minutes so um you know it's just what
your people get out of the way oh wait
there's thousands of you and so and one
of the one of the biggest challenges for
for new marriages whether it's a second
marriage third marriage or a first
marriage
is the idea that I'm gonna keep my old
life and just
um drop this new thing I've just done
into the middle of my old life I'm gonna
keep going to the same gym I'm gonna
keep hanging out with the same friends
I'm gonna keep doing the same stuff
and I'm just gonna also have this
marriage the ones that are successful
realize everything is on the table
because everything is new now we just
created a whole new life and there's
gonna be some things off the table and
there's a piece of things that we have
to give up it's things that we're going
to cause we're gonna change because the
marriage is priority because it's
priority now and when it's not priority
um now your statistics get bad that's
right Beth is in Denver hi Beth welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi I am so excited to be talking to you
guys you too Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas well I am calling to for y'all
to settle the score and my husband and I
are not necessarily having an argument
but we are having a debate about whether
he should buy a new truck or not you are
the most kind well we're not having an
argument we're having a debate we're
just having a debate well well said well
that's nice Merry Christmas
Beth just call it what it is it's not a
fight it's not a fight okay I am okay
but well I do think he's going to lose
but
um we have walked through the baby steps
and we're on set four five and six and
so he wants to buy a new truck and I
don't think what is your net worth
oh
our income is no 400 I don't know our
next income is 400.
okay how much do you have in your mutual
funds in in retirement do you think
okay what's your home worth
um it's worth 5
5 have 180 left to pay on it okay do you
own anything else of substance of large
value
no we just had a couple cars okay so if
we had 400 on your house plus 100 you
have a half a million dollar net worth
at roughly okay roughly yeah and you
make 400 000 a year so you're just now
getting to Baby Steps four five and six
you haven't been there long yes we've we
haven't been there very long time and
you haven't made 400 000 very long
um no okay
so uh it's a little bit early to buy a
new truck I we recommend it Ramsey and
have sent for 30 years not to buy a
brand new vehicle unless you have at
least a one million dollar net worth
you're going to be there fairly soon but
you're not going to be there right now
show you when the argument
well thanks that's assuming assuming I
actually hold the referee's whistle
which I'm not positive I do here but
um assuming you do I'll call him out of
bounds now I will say bye here's the
thing a brand new vehicle goes down in
value it loses 70 percent of its value
in the first four years you cannot
afford to take that big a hit until you
have a substantial amount of money and
then you can afford to lose that much
money and have a nice car but um when
you buy a fifty thousand dollar car it's
going to be worth 70 percent of that
what fifteen thousand bucks and about an
eye blink when you buy a hundred
thousand dollar car it's gonna be worth
thirty thousand so fast it will make you
throw up a little in the back of your
mouth it's ridiculous but you can afford
that if you've got two million dollars
I mean you can lose seventy thousand
dollars over three years if you got two
million bucks in order to drive a nice
car and you make 400 Grand you can
afford it that's okay but no I would not
buy a new car in your situation
I think so you think the only time is
after you have that you have a one
million dollar net worth
okay and then all of your vehicles
things with motors and wheels added
together should never add up to more
than half your annual income
so unless he's buying a Ferrari he's
probably okay you set a truck so you
know well you can get 120 000 truck but
um
you know but uh yeah we want to keep
your vehicles under 200 Grand all of
them added together
after you have a net worth of a million
dollars this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for being with us
America Merry Christmas to you our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping in the new promos
they run all the time you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal all right today's question
comes from Clark in Chicago Clark writes
things have been tight for us
financially this year and we haven't
been able to buy the big gifts we are
hoping to get for our kids how can we
navigate any possible meltdowns from the
kids that might come from being
disappointed by not getting what they
had been hoping for
oh man
Dave this is this question Changed by
age
um yes and it also changes by
um how far Upstream you want to get so
this is kind of like somebody asking
hey we're down by 32 runs in the bottom
of the ninth how do we win this game
well you're probably not going to win
this one because you're down by 32. and
you wait until the ninth inning too and
you suck at baseball that I would go
that far but but but you're right so I
uh in our house Sheila and I my wife
decided we're not doing a bunch of crazy
big gifts this year
um we're gonna do an experience and so
we started prepping the kids months out
Christmas is going to look and feel
differently this year we also reached
out to we have the only grandkids so I
got a real generous sister and brother
and sister-in-law and my parents and
they love to shower and we said hey this
year we're going smaller so we started
conversations on the front end and we've
started inviting our kids into more
giving things so they can see with their
own eyes and touch their own hands
people who are go without during
Christmas and so we started a
preparation for this moment a long time
ago
if we had just waited until Christmas
day and they wake up and they run down
there and there's no that's gonna be
tough and they're kids and let them if
kids get their feelings here it doesn't
bother me because they're little kids if
they're
9 10 11 12 13 on up that's when you can
start having different conversations but
man it's Christmas morning this is a
little bit late in the game to be having
this kind of conversation
it sounds more like
the kids are going to do what kids are
going to do
it feels like Clark feels like less of a
father because he's not able to buy the
things that make him feel good that he's
able to give to his kids and I think
Clark and his wife need to look in the
mirror and recognize they busted their
butt this year it was a tough year it
was a hard year and they provided for
those kids and they did a really good
job
yeah um in order to
let yourself off the hook you and your
wife sit down and try to name the big
gift that you got when you were a kid
on any Christmas
you probably don't remember a single one
if you remember one that might be good
if you remember two that's unusually
good doubt real seriously you remember
five Christmas gifts from five different
years
I remember one
I think it could I could probably come
up one or two yeah it was probably the
same Christmas I was having to dodge
dinosaurs because it was a long time ago
but um we got a stone wheel that's it I
got a wheel I got this new thing called
fire we got fire
um no the uh uh uh
so I guess my point is that they'll live
through it yes they will um and uh the
bigger deal you make about it the bigger
deal there's gonna be right
um but I do think that
um it's also the secret I use playing
golf
um the secret to happiness is low
expectations
yes exactly let's lower their little
expectations and some methodology age
appropriately
um if it's a 16 year old that's a
completely different discussion on
lowering expectations than if it's a
four-year-old and with a 16 year old you
say hey it's been a tough year and I
just want you to know coming out of the
gate there's going to be fewer prices
it's just going to be a little slim yeah
it can be tough just get your little
butt ready but with the younger ones if
you have younger ones you can say hey
Santa sent a letter
and said it's been tough times so
there's gonna be fewer gifts this year
but I want to provide you more time to
spend together set up a tent in your
living room and you all have a camp out
do something fun he said he loves you
extra special and whatever yeah I'll
remember that forever all that's good
and so you can create experiences and
um you know marshmallows still stuck in
the carpet four months later I don't
know whatever but um there's all kinds
of stuff you can do here that's not
um doesn't come out of a box because
we've all had the experience those of us
with a few years uh on us of the child
um it's three playing in the Box more
than playing with the item that came in
the Box
very distressing for the parent that
bought that thing from Neiman Marcus but
yeah
um so yeah that's so there is a even as
a grandfather I will admit
Um Papa Dave suffers from I am enjoying
this more than they're going to oh dude
I do too man I just want to watch
everything I'm let down that my children
have all told me I have to stop
overdoing it so it's it's it's just
ruined Christmas for me I'm just saying
but
um so I mean that's the thing so I think
Brad
um you know Clark Clark
this is from Clark wait a minute
Christmas vacation just emailed us right
here on the Ramsey Show well tile Cousin
Eddie we said hey Clark
um wow yeah and that you're not getting
the bonus from your Amino ball show no
pool
no pool man that's not coming so but I
do think this is did you guys do this no
you really didn't do it oh my God I mean
you guys are pranking Us in there this
is not this is real it's a form so
whoever did it might have been being
cute oh it just can't it yeah
but I don't I don't think Christmas
Vacation had a location did they was it
Chicago
some of you tweet in or email in let us
know because I don't know but uh trivia
for Christmas all right so I did want to
talk about this so sidebar turn a little
bit of an angle off of this
um
because I've got Dr John deloney here
own your past change your future 100
percent
of
adults that go and visit other adults
called their relatives at Christmas
bring some form of boundary issue some
form of
heavy to light trauma some form of uh
negative or positive memory
expanded in our brains to these these
singular Day events around Christmas
yeah and and speaking of setting
expectations and being grown-ups during
the holidays talk about navigating
family crap
that is in your own brain and is in
their brains and boundaries through
these holidays what are some basic ideas
or rules that well it's the strange
thing I experience is I and I wish there
was a less way of saying this
but I feel like my body becomes 14 again
I feel like I become a kid and I
instantly fall into I'm a middle child
and I've got an older sibling and a
younger sibling I feel like I just get
in this weird and I have to remind
myself wait a minute I got grown kids in
a house like and a wife I'm not 14
anymore and so hey I have to be
cognizant of myself what we did this
year what Sheila and I have done the
last few years is we send an email out
to the family and here's when we're
gonna be able to come here's what we
want to do here's some things that we
think will be fun anything y'all are
interested in doing and we like to do is
have those conversations the best we can
and our family works best in writing
before we get yeah but I mean when I get
there
I the years that I did not
pre think about perception and I'm not
14 I'm not the broke kid that came home
with your daughter and you didn't want
her to yeah marry and I didn't blame him
later but um I wouldn't let one one
would not have wanted my daughter to
marry the guy that came home with her
when it was me
um so either so I get that they weren't
mean about it um and they're still not
mean about it but
um the um I'm not that guy I have to
reset my mind intentionally before I bow
in the driveway that's right there's
some pre-planning relationally
psychologically you kind of have to do
otherwise you do fall right into that
hole don't you you do and I I start
getting sharp with people I start eating
too much so on the junk food table to
make myself feel a little bit better
um people will grab more drinks so I
think it's about knowing all I can
control in the situation is me and if
you want to poke some fun at me and have
some fun I'm Not Gonna Take It Personal
I'm not gonna push back I'm gonna smile
or I'm gonna take myself out of this
situation and that's really the two
options again I'm not discussing Trump
no I'm not discussing covid this is you
were not going to change anybody's
Jesus's birthday
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
Elijah is with us in Pittsburgh hey
Elijah welcome to the Ramsay show what's
up
hey Dave thank you how are you doing
today better than I deserve how can I
help
don't I'll dive right into it my parents
are up visiting for Christmas and money
conversations have come up a couple of
times nothing super specific but I know
that they have about 21 000 in cardet
and they're not on a budget at all my
wife and I are in baby step three but
one of the things that's most been
weighing on me is feeling like my
parents don't really have a retirement
plan in place
I'm almost 60 my dad's 58 she said she
wants to do something but she feels like
it's too late for them to start and even
if they did my dad is historically
set in his ways
um I know I can't change him they have
to do that so how do I Bridge
that's the way out that they can take
control
okay
um well I think you're accurate it's uh
one of the most frustrating things is
dealing with people that we love dearly
and trying to get them to do things that
are good for them
um and when you care more than they care
you know so
it is the old lead a horse to water
thing right you can't make them drink so
all we can do is lovingly lead them to
water and then release
and step back so whatever weight you are
feeling right now uh that whatever uh
sense of
um responsibility you feel right now
whatever sense of worry or uh you feel
on their behalf I want you to promise
that after you take two or three steps
you just lay that down
you got to step back
and just go I've done what I can do and
now that's up to them uh now if they
pick up and start running down the road
a little bit and then they need a little
more encouragement you can be their
biggest coach but you can't you you know
part of this deal is you offloading the
weight fair enough
yeah okay because you're worrying about
them and gonna work
because they're not worried about them
now there might be a mathematical
reality too okay in 20 years they're
gonna have nothing or in 30 years
they're going to have nothing and so we
might put a little money away in savings
or something once you guys get your
financial picture cleaned up but right
now y'all are still well it just gives
you a reason to be wealthy scratching
yeah you're going to want to help people
and they may be one of them but when
you're wealthy someday have you sat down
and had this conversation you've had it
with your mom have you sat down and
asked your dad just mano imano hey man
um
what's your do you have a will do you
have a plan
um what's your retirement plan look like
I've not conversations with him have
kind of just been surfacing
you know have they always been that way
or is it just yeah
yeah it's kind of always always vanilla
I want to challenge you over the
holidays if it's not going to create
drama
um if you said hey I'd love to take you
out dad and have a conversation
I've got the benefit my dad's a homicide
detective and so talking about death and
us not being here we've had that
conversation forever
um probably probably too much
um so that it was but it was still an
awkward conversation for me to Broach
like hey let's talk about will stop us
and he was awesome he had it all planned
out
um as most police officers do but
I do think it's worth sitting down and
saying at least broaching the subject
and it might not be this Christmas but
it may be a tiny little seed planted
that your dad needs to start having
these conversations or it may just
completely shut the door and like Dave
said it makes it much easier to
set those bricks down and quit carrying
them when they're when the door is shut
and sealed does that make sense so in
other words you sit down over a cup of
coffee or beer and you go Dad I'm
worried about you and mom
um tell me what you got planned I'm
working on my money stuff and I'm just
now starting to get it figured out and I
remember how scared I was and I think
Mom's kind of scared so tell me what you
got planned and is there any way I can
help you because I'm starting to learn
about this stuff and if he says mind
your own dadgum business go jump in a
creek then do just that
that's your only option he told you
exactly where you stand and he might I
don't know who this guy is or he might
go yeah I don't really have anybody to
talk to about it I'm so scared I can't
breathe
and for the first time in your life or
the first time in recent decades you
might have a really deep conversation
with him emotionally that's right and
and Dave said it best lead with your
vulnerability not what he's doing wrong
no never you do not need to wag a finger
particularly at this guy yeah he's old
school I'm just now figuring out how
expensive it is to be an adult in this
world and it got me thinking about man
you guys are well my wife and I are
working this Ramsay plan and I'm so I'm
so first time ever I'm starting to see
how this stuff works and I'm
simultaneously not as scared as I was
and I'm some and excited about the
future and it kind of got me looking
over there and I was remembering looking
at mom's eyes the other day how scared I
was and I kind of think she might be and
I don't know maybe even you but is there
some you know tell me tell me you're
okay tell me you got a million dollars
or or tell me to go my own business and
pound sand but I just want to ask you
about this because I love you and it's
just a subject I've gotten excited about
yeah and just understand that especially
with with with with certain Generations
this the shame around how much you have
or don't have is so powerful and so
great you may get a response that has
nothing to do with you and that has
everything to do with him it's every
generation and uh it is it is but
um
at least you will be able to sleep at
night knowing hey I had this
conversation I broach the subject I'm
setting the sucker down yeah and then
just you know it's if I can show you
what I've learned uh and so here's the
thing A Guy taught me about uh he he
said if you tell your story
no one can debate you about your story
time but when you start trying to tell
them their story everybody wants to
debate about their own story they go you
don't know what you're talking about you
don't know what's happening here you
know but I I'm not gonna don't wag your
finger and uh there's probably some
pretty obvious things they're doing that
are stupid butt stuff but but don't even
go there don't bring her what about the
car loan don't even bring it up just let
him go yeah I got this card debt and if
you can get him to pull pull them into
it rather than push them into the
conversation then maybe you get there
and then you go hey man you know uh you
know I went through this thing and you
know here's a website to look at her I
went here's a YouTube clip these people
yelling that they're out of debt and
here's a guy that you know was 17 years
there uh in 2017 had nothing and he went
through this plan now he's a millionaire
and there's all those clips on YouTube
you can watch you know and
um I mean we've had like a billion
downloads now or something so um
you know that kind of thing and you're
just sharing information that you have
experienced and just stay over there
and um so uh and my pastor used to say a
man with an experience is not the mercy
of a man with an opinion you know I
don't believe in all that get out of
debt stuff well that's okay I understand
but uh but I'm really enjoying being out
of debt but I remember if uh this is
years ago now but I um had a friend
who's had a parent who I think had a
stroke or passed away and
um no we didn't pass away but almost and
I remember asking my parents
hey do y'all have like a plan what if
one of y'all has a heart attack has a
stroke and nothing there nothing came of
that conversation but the next year for
Christmas they bought the kids they
bought themselves long-term care
insurance as our Christmas present and I
thought that was fantastic and we all
cheered and it was great but it took
them a while they talked about it they
went and met with their financial advice
or whatever but it was again it was a
seed that was planted like oh yeah we
don't really haven't thought about what
happens if
they never answered the question but
then they went and answered the question
they went into the question that's right
yeah yeah it's um it's interesting to
lead people lead your children your
grown kids which is always an oxymoron
right but I mean your 30 year old your
25 year old how do you communicate with
them because you can't you can't use
your dad voice
you know it doesn't work because they
don't have to listen anymore they like
make their own money and stuff and so
you have to use your friend voice and
it's like you know it's like I'm your
friend and I want to persuade you
because you're being an idiot and you
know but you can't say any of that but
it'll be going through your head it's
like huh you know maybe I don't know
when I used to do that I felt this way
and you know it's just like I've tried
that and it didn't work out well I had a
counseling Professor say whenever
somebody's making a dumb Choice instead
of telling them you should be doing this
you can tell them
yeah you could try that and um
I'll buy the first round when this thing
implodes I'll be here when this goes
sideways and uh
it's a great way to communicate I
wouldn't do that I'm not saying I
wouldn't do that oh hey and parents over
the holidays if your kids get the
courage to ask and have a hard
conversation about wills it beat with
them be graceful they're trying they're
practicing all these things we're
teaching be graceful with them yeah
don't be a butt
or that it's Jesus's birthday don't be a
boy this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
well do work that they actually love and
create real amazing relationships Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book own
your past change your future is my
co-host today Elizabeth is with us
Elizabeth is in Pensacola Florida Merry
Christmas Elizabeth
Merry Christmas Dave thank you and John
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas how can
we help
okay thank you I um I've been in a
relationship for uh coming up on one
year
um with a man who's loving and devoted
father to his two girls and I also have
a daughter and we started off so wide
open and hopeful and we were discussing
the possibility and dream of marriage
and blending our families and how that
could work but little by little issues
regarding lots of things including
boundaries with the kids have seemed to
put a huge damper on our relationship
and due to his behavior moods my
daughters pretty much lost all respect
for him and despises him now and at this
point our relationship is unrecognizable
from a year ago since I've retreated to
where it felt I wouldn't step on any
toes out of deference and respect
but I'm also struggling with a feeling I
should walk away but also not wanting to
abandon what we've tried to build
how old is your daughter
13 and a half
they're perfectly capable of causing
entire countries to cave in
they also 13 year olds
um I was just talking about this on my
show earlier today
they're they're sonar
for not safe is often much more in tune
than ours
are as adults because like you just
mentioned you've got a fantasy
you can't you've come from heartbreak
you want to the idea of a family and you
meet this guy and right out of the gate
it's going to be awesome and all of a
sudden the the the picture you all paint
together looks incredible
and then reality starts to open up over
the last year and you have enough
strength and fortitude and grit
determination I'm gonna marry this guy I
don't care if he's the worst guy I I
want that picture and your 13 year old
saying I'm not gonna be around him
because she's still in touch with she
hasn't lost that sense of herself yet
here's my my hard hard question for you
sounds like you've already broken up
with him you haven't broken up the
fantasy
yeah
I just like and John on your
recommendation I bought that book love
uh facing love addiction uh by Pian
Melody and I I'm trying to look at
myself and say is this just you know but
I I do I love him and care about him so
much and it it's just hard to let go
because
both of those things can be true at the
same time
you can love somebody deeply and they're
not the right person to connect to hit
your wagon to for the rest of your life
you can break up with somebody and be
devastated and still be the right thing
to do
those things aren't mutually exclusive
and I'm not telling you to dump him I
would never tell somebody to do that
unless there's abuse or something so I'm
not telling you got to leave them what
I'm just holding up a mirror to what you
just told me and Dave is you're done
with this relationship you're not done
with the idea of what could have been
which bucket
um
your 13 year old doesn't want anything
to do with him she's lost all respect
for him is it because he called her out
on her stuff and no one has lately and
she's a little 13 year old butt or is it
because
um she's seeing stuff that you know is
right
you know trying to tell her hey why does
she not respect him exactly
um he gets kind of Moody and she thinks
that he's not acting like mature and I
agree those times where he gets like
triggered by things and he'll kind of
act moody or her or something and it's
like I think she's looking just like I
am for that leader and I've Got The
Compassion treasure like oh I'll work
with him I'll work with and she's just
like nah you know she's when you say
moody is it that Sunday afternoon dad
just that there's a bear over there on
the couch watching football you better
not talk to him or touch him or is it is
he ugly does he suggly things he just
ignore people what do you mean be
specific about the behaviors
um so like uh for instance sometimes
um even specifically towards her like he
kind of didn't give a benefit of the
doubt for something let's say and you
know and he kind of acted like she
wasn't
um acting right when she was just being
a normal kid or or also you know just
the way that she's seen him interact
with because he's got a a thought or two
with her age and so you know I'm sure
they chat you know and so just seeing
how sometimes he reacts to her and then
the daughter's reaction to that there's
like I didn't even go into some things
that she's seen that I also wasn't okay
with over it his place where just
there's some family Dynamics there that
I'm not like
both you and him have been around the
block meaning y'all have been through
heartbreak y'all have had you've had
other marriages before you've had other
relationships
is there an opportunity for y'all to sit
down with adult like like in a very
adult conversation almost like a like an
accounting review
um an audit and just say hey this last
year's been tough
Let's either let's agree that we're
gonna we're gonna start acting different
we want this thing to work and we're
going to both begin to or continue to
invest in this thing or let's
we're going to be heartbroken and it's
going to be hard but let's choose to
move on could you do that could you have
that conversation and for the and say
some of your needs out loud
yeah and I've been trying to and it
seems like he kind of like doesn't
um I don't know if he's really very
available to give me what I need which
also and I even sent used some words I
heard on your show like I'm worth you
know being loved from who I am or like
I'm worth this I have a lot to offer and
like I'm you know and he's kind of like
I don't know he just I don't I don't
think he actually appreciates my my
worth and I'm trying to I don't know I
think maybe that's also part of it too
you're done yeah I mean that's what
you're telling us you just you just
outline somebody that's done
and I wanted and Dave I like want
someone to treat me like how you treat
Sharon I want John I want someone to
treat me like how you treat you like I
want that and I just your daughter
doesn't because I would be dismissal
dismissive of her if she was if your
household is kids Centric and your kid
thinks she's the old be-all and she's
13. I would be dismissive of her so you
really wouldn't want me
and I'm not like some Diva no not you
her
you get to be on the pedestal that's
your job the 13 year old doesn't
right right and that's what I feel like
I feel like and I literally put my hand
down on the ground I was like I feel
like I'm down here and like let's say
his you know mom and his sister and your
mom or sister are there
oh you should have left with my you
should have lived with Mom LED with Mama
yeah
hey here's what here's what you what um
your uh your body's gearing up for
another breakup and it remembers the
last one and it was painful and awful so
get some people in your life because
you're about to enter into a hard season
yeah and uh get some hot tea and two
good friends we'll we'll walk alongside
you this one's done be tough it's done
stick a fork in it I'm sorry honey I'm
sorry
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
Dr trondaloni Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I got good news for all
you guys and gals out there who are
planners and are looking to head to make
big changes in 2023 the ten dollar sale
is on
yeah it's our biggest ten dollar sale
yet you'll find plenty to inspire and
motivate you for the coming year some of
the newcomers to the 10 sale are my
number one bestseller recent baby steps
millionaires Ken Coleman's number one
bestseller from paycheck to purpose the
conversation cards questions for humans
by Dr John deloney The Total Money
Makeover lots and lots and lots and lots
most of our books number ones most of
them ten dollars so check it out all at
ramseysolutions.com do not miss this
this is the time to get the best deals
and for most of you I think we can still
get them to you for by Christmas I don't
know how this stuff's working all right
John so uh before I get all the hate
mail
um
you and I have talked about this several
times and let's get some clarity on it
um
how do you balance on that last caller
as a single mom in that situation
being too kid-centric and putting a 13
year old on a pedestal and giving them
too much
credit for wisdom that they really don't
have uh and therefore empowering them to
be little brats in a sense where like
they're in charge of your adult
relationship or something they can't
carry that how do we balance that with
you said they've got a great radar
because it's unfiltered and they they do
have a sense about things which they do
so I'm not completely disrespecting or
discounting the kid's opinion but um
you've said a lot of times and I've
agree with you that we are a little bit
too not a little bit we were way too kid
Centric way in this culture where
everything revolves around a little
child what tipped this conversation for
me was
moms and Mom knew
mom knows this thing was the 13 year old
was just the truth teller that's right
the 13 year old was the unfortunately
the Oracle in that house and had said
some things out loud that mom had been
feeling and thinking all along and so it
was Mom saying this thing has has
degraded over the last years not what we
thought it's not who he's not who I
thought he was he's immature and then
she we could have pushed a little bit
more she would have told us some stuff
that would have made her hair
curl up well we finally got to Mama but
yeah so in this situation daughter was
just was the only one with the courage
to tell the truth yeah
so
um
you because usually the reverse happens
when somebody is is met somebody new
it's going great they respect him yeah I
don't want people to to hear you say is
because you didn't say it is a
belligerent arrogant teenager is not the
Oracle no in your house they're just
being a teenager but that's
hormone-induced and they don't have the
position of power to decide what I get
to do I'm the dad right um and on the
other hand
they also you know but that that's
assuming then that I'm also big enough
as the dad or the mom to listen to what
they have to say and that they do
actually have feelings feelings
absolutely and I want to I want to teach
a uh I'm not going to put the the weight
of the of all the responsibilities in
the house on a teenager because they
can't carry that weight it's not fair
it's cruel to do that to a kid to ask
them all the time where do you want to
eat and what do you want to do and where
do you want a kid can't handle that and
also
I want to begin to teach them let them
practice autonomy so hey we're gonna go
eat one of these two places which one
you want to pick
they get to pick from those two choices
that that I put out there right so we're
going to slowly teach them that but in
this situation that kid was just telling
the truth don't make me let him do that
last night the seven-year-old picked
between ravioli and Tacos there you go
and that that seven-year-old is gonna
Flex all week being like I I told Mimi
what we were having for dinner yeah okay
that's cool all right that that I mean
because there's a thing happening here
that's
um
we're not like some kind of old school
dinosaurs where we're saying that the
child does not have a voice and you're
not trying to teach them that because my
friend Andy Andrews said we're trying to
we're not trying to raise kids to be
great kids we're trying to raise them to
be great adults adults that's right
which is approach and adult conversation
with someone else's relationship with
humility right that's how you do it as
an adult
and so and it's how you do it by God
when you're 13. that's right you know so
uh and there's and there's there's uh
the mistake I made early on
um with with one of my kids was
they would say something and I would say
no you don't when it came to I'm scared
or I'm I've this hurt and I would say no
it doesn't no it didn't well that's not
I'm teaching you not to trust yourself
that's dumb what I should say in those
situations is I'm sorry that it hurts we
still have to go or I'm sorry that
you're scared
I'm going to put a light on but you
still have to sleep in this bed right so
it's both and it's not a dismissal of
you and it's also not I we still have
responsibilities and I'm teaching you I
don't want to get up and go to work
today but I got to right yeah sometimes
there's grown-up stuff to be done that's
right all right Bonita is with us in
Lansing Michigan hi Bonita how are you
um pretty good how about you better than
I deserve what's up
um so
I've been listening to you for a few
months now and I've been trying to pay
off this a little bit of debt I have and
as well I got my boyfriend listening to
you and paying uh we pay his debt off
and everything
um and things have been going good but
then I um you know I'm taking a gap Year
from school this year I'm in college
um and yesterday I found out that I
didn't unenroll from the classes
in time like I thought I did and now I'm
on the hook for about 10 grand
that I need to pay
um that I wasn't expecting to pay
and I feel like it just kind of put a
wrench in my plans uh that's a lot of
money for me and I just I don't know I
don't really know what I would go down
and meet with the registrar's office
and let them know exactly what you did
and you say I
had a lot going on and I screwed up and
I didn't withdraw from these classes I
never attended these classes I haven't
been a student here can you help me out
I don't have ten thousand dollars to
write you a check right now
and I will tell you I've worked at
universities that would say absolutely
we'll take care of you and I've worked
at universities that would say sorry we
have to go by the policy
I'll also tell you that the reason I'm
in this seat right now
is because I was taking a master's level
counseling class as an administrator and
I registered for that class like in
April it was a summer class I completely
forgot about it
and I went to register for the fall
classes I was just taking a class here
and there and I had an F on my
transcript so I called the I emailed the
professor and said hey I never went to
the class I got an F okay and she goes
no you didn't show up to my class you
got an F and then I went up across
campus and I said hey I can't have an F
on my transcript and she said I will
take care of this but you have to go to
my child play therapy class at that time
I would rather set myself on fire than
go to a child's play therapy class and I
went and then we ended up
um she said what are you doing getting a
master's degree and you get a degree and
she ended up being the reason I'm in
Nashville Tennessee so I tell you that
to tell you this
if you made a mistake own the mistake
somebody might help you out and it may
be the best thing that ever happened to
you and it may be that you just got to
pay ten thousand bucks and move on I
sure hope you don't but uh in person
in person Tick Tock DM
or whatever the crap Tic Tac or whatever
you don't just go in there in person sit
down like a human and don't blame them
blame yourself take all the ownership
yeah humble what we used to call hat in
hand
I messed up please give me mercy I'm
begging for mercy I am here to fall
before your desk and ask for Mercy
that's right and um I goofed up by three
days or five days or whatever I thought
I did it properly I was stressed out I'm
taking a gap year because I'm broke and
I'm certainly so too broke to pay ten
thousand dollars and so please help me
one other
loophole might be
can you at least give me incomplete on
these grades so I can take them again
when I get done with my Gap Year and
that may be a way not to get your money
back but to preserve so you have to pay
for those classes twice that might be
something you can do also but hopefully
it'll give you your money back
you can probably get that
hopefully they'll just say yeah we deal
with college age people and sometimes
they mess up
because all people mess up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage will and Kendall are
with us hey guys how are you we're good
how are you better than we deserve where
do you live live in Memphis Tennessee
very fun welcome to Nashville Merry
Christmas to you yeah Merry Christmas to
y'all how much data have you paid off
28 000. all right how long did that take
about five months good and your range of
income during that time went from about
forty thousand to seventy two thousand
very cool what do you all do for a
living
so I'm in nursing school so I graduate
in May all right yep and then I work at
a Content creation agency in Memphis and
we just specialize in commercial photo
and video and then on the side I'm a
Ramsey Certified Financial coach oh wow
look at you well done Coco what kind of
debt was this 28 000. so it was a car
loan and then uh student loans that she
took out earlier and uh so we would
knock those off and now we're just cash
flow in the rest of our school I love it
good nursing is a great degree well you
got five months more of being the
breadwinner dude yep she's gonna take
the keys that's fine with me that works
for me exactly it's all good how long
you all been married uh six months yeah
we got married in June oh gross how's it
going it's going good it's great yeah
six whole months how old are you guys
I'm 22 and I'm 21. all right way to go
you guys and you're a 21 year old Ramsay
Financial Coke yes sir my goodness
that's impressive okay so you get
married and uh I mean Kendall you signed
up for this I mean you sign up with a
Ramsey Financial coach gotta help you
exactly you know so you get married
what's the first thing you got to do we
got to get rid of these debts exactly
and I'm guessing that um that will the
car loan wasn't even yours oh it
actually was it was yours oh good we got
we can spread the guilt around this yeah
we can I can good that's good awesome
okay so tell me the story how you guys
start talking about this and then what
you did to get out of debt yeah so we
actually took foundations in high school
um but at the same time it really never
clicked for either one of us she took it
as a sophomore I took it as a senior and
it wasn't until covid I just
was working and started binging the
podcast and the YouTube and I've
obviously heard of you from high school
and honestly I just started binging it
and I really started to understand what
the mission and uh doll's values here at
Ramsey like what it actually means and
so that really
for both of us we were like we don't
want to live
like we see in the world from people
that are close to us we didn't want to
live and be normal like that so we
decided obviously when we were getting
married that we weren't going to do that
and so from then
um obviously when we got married we
started doing it I started coordinating
FPU so in January I'll have my fourth
class my goodness and so we're just
fired up honestly we're just excited so
so how much grief do the old people in a
class give a 21 year old coordinator
yeah it's always funny I walk in and
I'll be greeting people just kind of
casually walking around introducing
myself and then they have no idea who I
am until I get up at the front and start
saying uh like greeting everyone and
it's always funny to see everybody's
face when they see that I'm actually
teaching the class
um but now you can show the video to
start the class of this interaction
that'd be great yeah and so that was one
thing that we really wanted is that
we're not just someone that's
putting the video up and playing it like
we're in we're doing it with y'all
um and that's what I tell everybody that
we come into contact with like we're on
this same Journey with you we're doing
it as well all right so Kendall you had
a picture
since for years
of your first year or two of marriage
yes
yes it probably included fewer beans and
Rice's than you've beans and rice and
you've eaten in the last six months
that's very true there's we were we were
talking about this on the way here like
I mean when you get married like you
wanna we just moved into an apartment
like we want to furnish it get it all
cute but we had to be okay with you know
we got a free couch from the church like
we just you know furnished it how we
could you know because we were paying
off debt we didn't have the money to go
you know buy a couch and a table and all
that so when you get a free couch from a
church that means they got the free
couch from someone else this is the
third time
there's so many butts that have been on
the couch exactly and it's not a very
pretty color either but okay this is
good because we had we had a call in the
earlier segment is your marriage somehow
less than no not at all if anything it's
better
um it's brought us closer together I
mean we're on the same page financially
and so when y'all already say when you
get on the same page like things start
to just
it's just building up and you're going
in the right direction and I feel like
we're closer because we've done this
together we both it wasn't just me that
wanted this she wanted it as well which
was really cool and I was thankful for
that we have the same values when it
comes to money and marriage and so it's
it's been really cool how does it feel
to be free amazing amazing amazing and
you've been able to cash flow the rest
of nursing school yes yeah well done
y'all yeah you guys got such an
incredible start you're gonna be able to
be unbelievably generous and
unbelievably wealthy both very very cool
very cool okay now you're leading the
class you're debt free you paid off 28
000 in the first five months of marriage
and someone says okay Hot Shot what is
it you do to get out of debt what are
the what are the things you got to do if
you're going to get out of debt what are
the keys
um honestly obviously the budget but we
talk about this a lot just being content
like with what you have like all of our
friends you know our friends that also
get married
um you know may have
a new couch and a new this and that but
us just being content knowing like this
is our plan this is what we're gonna do
and it was five months like I know
people have longer Journeys than that
and so we knew for five months we can do
this and then you know now we we did get
a new couch so our Apartments come
together so yeah
we are butts yes yeah and I'd agree with
that you always say get on a plan and
stick with it
um and that's what I always tell people
if during FPU if you will submit to this
plan and give it a hundred and ten
percent it will work for you it doesn't
it's not just for low income or high
income families it's for anybody that's
willing to submit to the plan and that's
with a lot of things in life it's not
just money if you are willing to put the
work in submit to the plan like your
life can change for the better all right
closed circuit to all you people in
Memphis if you want to go to the the
best possible Financial Peace class I
think I just found the coordinator wow
that was incredible very well done if
you want to coach in Memphis I think we
just found him excellent job dude very
very well done powerful stuff you two
and and if you want a nurse to jab you
with needles I want a nurse who wants to
be there or not who has to be there yes
exactly very cool I do wow hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you uh it
includes the baby steps millionaires
book it includes The Total Money
Makeover book and a one-year membership
probably some gifts you'll give away and
maybe you can enjoy at least the baby
stuff's millionaires book you're going
to be those before you know it no doubt
you guys are incredible powerful young
couple wow excellent job well done well
done all right it's will and Kendall
Memphis Tennessee 28 000 paid off in the
first five months of marriage making 40
to 72 when she graduates from college
and becomes a nurse watch out watch out
here it goes count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh if I had had one ounce of that much
since when I was 21 just one ounce when
I was 21 I saw no the depot had already
dug myself and I was like when they
brought a shovel I didn't make that
deeper let's go see how deep we can go I
kept digging until it's about 36 years
old way to go you guys you're impressive
awesome hey that's the power of that
High School curriculum right there this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER of the day Romans 15 13 May the hope
of May the god of Hope fill you with all
joy and peace and believing so that by
the power of the Holy Spirit you may
abound in Hope
C.S Lewis said Joy is the serious
business of Heaven
love it Nick is with us Nick is in Salt
Lake City Utah hi Nick how are you
good how are you too better than we
deserve how can we help
Cricket
um I'll try to make us brief I'm trying
to figure out if I should leave my toxic
work environment yes and go yes to my
old
okay
tell us about yourself what's toxic
about it
so
um a little back story I had to come
here to get benefits from because my
previous Place didn't have any benefits
and so
we
my family had a major crisis in our
lives where
my wife tried to
sorry
take your life
sorry that's okay so you had to take
this job for the for the insurance so
she could get the care that she needed
correct yeah because we couldn't
actually have to go
from when she wasn't a kid she was
recommended to go to a psychiatrist a
therapist I'm sorry
um for
you know two times a week and we got it
down to one time a week but paying out
of pocket was just going to be where
we would have been homeless and we have
a one-year-old or you're about to be one
and we just didn't see a solution for it
we how long how long ago was that
in 2020 last year it was around November
so a little over a year ago hey can I
just stop you right here and applaud you
for being a husband who loves his wife
enough to do whatever it takes
thank you it's you're an impressive
Brave man and I'm proud to get to share
a conversation with you man you quit a
job that you liked in order to take a
job that you had to take so that you
could care for your family and that's
what people do in hard times and I'm
proud of you
thank you so it sounds like this new job
provides medical benefits but also
pretty awful too
yeah so I I took it because it was a
higher paying job and when we got the
medical bill it was
very high where we're obviously in bed
right now and so that was the main
reason for us for the benefits of paper
therapy as well as be able to pay for
the medical bill just to get out of it
and what do you mean about a Year's
worth of salary
um at this new place to make it up for
me 78th doing what at the old place
um engineering you're an engineer
yes
okay
and how old are you
I am 20 about the 28th so you've been
licensed three years four years
no no so I just started working about
two and a half years ago so we we didn't
know about you guys until you know I'm
asking how long have you been an
engineer
oh yeah for about two and a half years
only okay all right and what's the
problem at the new place what's the
Define what toxic means in this case
so anytime I get yelled at on a weekly
basis and there's been times where I've
been yelled at in front of my colleagues
and have been threatened that if I don't
get get it right then I'm going to be
out of here the next day okay let me
stop you saying okay are you being
confronted
about performance or are you being
yelled at with actual volume
yeah with actual volume
okay
all right yeah here's this is a I'm
going to ask this directly and kind of I
mean it's hard
is this you being like it's hurting my
feelings or is this no dude this dude's
like getting all up in my face like if
we were outside there'd be a problem
kind of kind of yelling at you
yeah everywhere outside there'll be a
problem that's what and that's where I'm
not sure what to do because I can handle
it then I can take it but it's to the
point where it's just becoming I would
think there'll be a lot of engineering
jobs in Salt Lake City that included
medical benefits
ever have you looked yet
yeah I've looked at a couple different
areas and tried to apply to a few
different places and a lot of them are
hiring and I've had a couple interviews
with them however there's just we're in
a small town where
if I were to go there it's about a 45
minute commute to an hour commute for me
to get to the other places that I'm
interested in I'm not going to do that
more than I can be yelled at because my
yelling button is fairly low mine too
like one time
um I also can consider
um moving communities if I have to move
a little bit closer to where I work we
all locked into this community that
you're a part of right now
yeah so we have a house we bought it a
couple years ago and so we have we do
have a house and the reason we're living
where we are right now is because we
have parents that are close by that can
watch a little boy especially right now
since she's working part-time so we can
try to pay off this debt they're going
up therapy it's
we're just both trying to pay it off as
fast as we can sure
I don't want you to lose your
relationship or your sanity in the
process
okay
okay yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta
have to do something else and we just
got to find out what and it may be it
may be pick your poison uh I'm picking
I'll make a commute before I get yelled
at
I'm picking I'm going to keep looking
and looking and looking and find
something very soon because it's not
going to be long for I tell this guy to
take this job and shove it
you
know like I mean like 30 seconds so I'm
because I'm a redneck it's hard for me
to put up with that stuff I'm
I mean I get all hillbilly on you that
ain't gonna work I don't do yelling you
know and you're just thinking about you
experiencing that can you imagine
we actually had a team member a while
back a few years ago yell at one of our
leaders here and he fired him on the
spot and it's like he goes why are you
firing me was like because we like our
civilized human beings in here you you
know you're done you belligerent little
twerp and say oh my God yeah man your
instincts and your guts are right I'm
with Dave I would rather come home with
Integrity 30 minutes later every day and
what I mean by Integrity not brow
beating down and not exhausted and not
hating my life but I do think that you
know don't put too many constraints on
this there's no way to do this except in
this other bad way right there's you
know sometimes if the only options I've
got are two bad ones that means I don't
have enough options right and so I want
you to go keep looking and poking and
looking and poking and looking and
poking and find you something or open up
your own engineering thing on the side
and drive Uber at night I don't know but
um you know let's do something different
very very quickly
like I don't like the end of January you
have a new job Nick that's what I'm
prescribing I'm telling you to go do
that
okay perfect does that make sense
and yeah you know I don't care it might
be that you buy your own health
insurance and you get paid 100 at the
other place
instead of 70. okay that makes sense
I'll do that one too I mean I don't you
know benefits are good but they're not
worth 60 000 bucks a year so I mean if
you can make more money someplace else
and you don't have a commute and you got
to buy your own health insurance have at
it that's right but your dignity doesn't
have a price tag brother yeah and just
you you know well I mean it's dignity
it's also just
Humanity it's just you know we're just
not gonna act like these what are you
who yells in the and I mean it's not
like this is a
a ditch digging firm or something I mean
this is an engineer's who thinks they
can get I mean here's the thing they can
get away with it high paid white-collar
job somebody who's gotten away with it
yeah nobody who hires brand new newly uh
certified engineers and just and
overpays them so he can abuse them or
possibly underpays them and runs them
into the ground and gets what he wants
they leave and he has his bad attitude
and starts it over again where are you
going don't have any payments not here
that's right that's right
that's somewhere else not here not today
you are confused individual
[Laughter]
oh man but hey uh Kudos man for for
doing the hard thing and yeah quitting a
job stud Nick loving your words throw
your shoulders back step into the next
thing because you're good at stepping
into the next thing you've done a good
job with it and uh
yeah yeah that place is not deserving of
someone with as much character as you
have sir exactly right that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books
thanks to Austin Ben James Zach and
Andrew in the booth they're known as the
booth dudes they make this happen we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]